growing political and legal fallout from
the supreme court's decision to overturn
roe v wade as a result of that ruling
abortion bans are enacted expected or
likely to be enacted in at least 20
states
in arkansas a trigger law immediately
banned nearly all abortions there are no
exceptions for minors or in cases of
rape or incest the only exception is if
the mother's life is at risk
that law was signed in 2019 by governor
aza hutchinson who joins us this morning
from little rock governor it is good to
see you happy friday happy independence
day weekend
thank you we're excited about the
weekend and it's good to be with you
today
well thank you again so your state has
given about a million dollars to
pregnancy centers
but that's a fraction of what's likely
going to be needed
for the thousands of unwanted
pregnancies that are going to occur each
year now what else might you and your
state legislature be planning to do to
help young mothers and families
well it's an important question and we
are addressing it and first of all we
started this long before you know we
took a medicaid expansion in arkansas
that provided health coverage for
the working poor
we're trying to improve our health care
for
maternal moms for prenatal care but what
we do now and you start with the fact
that last year we had about 3 000
abortions in arkansas
and so under the
new law that the supreme court allowed
to take effect that means that a
significant number of those will be
reduced
some of those moms will put the child up
for adoptions we're going to have to
increase our adoption services
others will go out of state which i
think will be a small minority
but there will be many that will carry
that child to term and to keep that
child and so we want to make sure that
we have the wraparound services
for that mom both
during the pregnancy but also afterwards
so we're
looking as to how we can beef that up
i've charged my health department and
human services to come up with some more
funding for each of those needs that we
see as a result of this so we should
anticipate more funding for
psychological issues potentially
stemming from unwanted births or
physical issues with pregnancies and
births
and and also there's this report now
that at least two arkansas state
senators say they're looking to
introduce legislation to ban women from
traveling out of state to get an
abortion is that a law you would sign
i would not
the challenge there is that
that would be in violation of interstate
commerce obviously we want to discourage
that because the public policy in
arkansas
is to
limit abortions and to
carry out the will of the people and so
we recognize that that
is something that even the united states
supreme court addressed in one of the
concurring opinions that this is not
intended to restrict interstate commerce
the supreme court decision said each
state is going to make its own decisions
in this which is traditional public
health matters arkansas has made its
decision other states might look at it
differently
governor over the last few weeks we have
learned more details about january 6 and
trump's role on the violence that the
nation witnessed that day representative
liz chaney called trump quote domestic
threat we have never seen before do you
agree do you believe that he is a danger
to this nation
well as you can see from the
testimony on january 6 and and
subsequent to the election where he was
challenging the legality of it the
lawful transfer of party yes that was a
threat to our democracy
that was a threat to our institutions of
government and that's not the behavior
we want to see in a responsible
president
i think the question for the january 6
committee is
one you get facts out to the public
which is important to know
secondly they're trying to make a case
that there's criminal conduct on behalf
of the president i question whether
they have made that case i don't believe
they have i don't know whether they can
but the justice department is watching
that
and we'll see how that develops but at
this point they have not made that
criminal conduct case in my judgment
but you agree with the congresswoman
that he's a danger to the nation that's
what you're saying
well i've
everybody phrases it a different way i
would not be supporting him for 2024
he acted irresponsibly during that time
he was a risk to the nation absolutely
so that's that's my statement on it
what did you make of cassidy
hutchinson's testimony this week
very compelling i mean any
one who appreciates the difficulty of
someone being 25 and thrust into that
incredible
closeness to history and
what even in in her young age understood
to be fundamentally wrong and she
testified to it so
my heart goes out to those that really
stood firm during that time and i think
she clearly demonstrated her
concern and love for our country
did you believe her governor did you
believe her did you believe what she
what she told us
i did she came across with a great deal
of credibility but what's a challenge
with the committee is that they're not
having cross-examination they're not
having other points of view and so that
makes it more difficult i'm a lawyer i'm
used to the adversary system where you
have different points of view presented
and that was eliminated secondly they
got into hearsay and that's where
if they can't back that up it undermines
that testimony so i want them to be
careful the committee that they present
this in as fair a manner as they can
make sure they really have the facts as
they presented
many agree with you on that point but i
want to get to 2024 because you have
said out loud that you're considering a
presidential bid in 2024 and president
trump will not former president trump
will not be a factor in your decision
most people don't say that out loud
what's your thinking here
well
i answer questions honestly and while
we're totally focused on 2022
obviously there's talk about 2024 and i
had to make it clear that
trump has disqualified himself in my
judgment from his actions on january 6
and leading up to that and so we have to
go a different direction for our country
for uh my party
and so
i want to be a voice for common sense
conservatism and we'll see how that
resonates but let's get through 2022
we've got a very important election
ahead
i know governor but it sounds like
you're considering challenging him if he
decides to run in 2024 can you said you
answer the questions that you're asked
would you would you run in 2024
well i'm
what i'm doing is consistent with that i
haven't made a commitment to it i
haven't made a decision on it but i'm
laying the foundation for that if that
is something that's going to be helpful
to our country so we're looking at it
but no decision we made till after this
election in 2022.
okay we look forward to your
announcement right here at the table at
cbs mornings we got a seat right over
there on the left keep it warm for you
governor
we look forward to seeing you again
thank you so much governor for coming on
again we always like to see you